A TWITTER ARMY:
I don’t think you realize how crazy Saudi
Arabia’s propaganda room is. 40% of all tweets
from the Arab World come from Saudi Arabia much
of which comes from this single room. Using this
army, Saudi Arabia’s crown prince, Mohammed Bin
Salman or MBS is able to push whatever story he
wants to the absolute top. #VISION_2030. Trending.
#Riyadh_rising. Trending. #MBS_Rocks. Trending.
Not only does this room push certain narratives
to the top but it also pushes opposing narratives
to the bottom. If you have any sort of relavance
within the Arab world and you post something
that’s not in the Saudi family’s best interest,
well then, this army is gonna flood your post with
negative comments and dislikes. We may even see
these trolls under this video. At first, Twitter
tried to take down this army by deleting thousands
of their fake accounts. At one point, they had
deleted as many as 88,000 accounts but eventually,
even Twitter gave up. The problem is that these
tweets aren’t coming from bots. We’re talking
about hundreds of real people working full time
on this effort making it extremely difficult to
identity. And ever since Elon bought Twitter,
all hopes of this army being taken down have
been completely crushed. You see, Elon didn’t
buyout Twitter single handedly. He had several
investors pitch in and his biggest investor was
none other than Saudi Prince Alwaleed. With no one
else willing to fight against this propaganda,
the Saudi people have taken this matter into
their own hands through a movement called the bee
movement. The idea is pretty simple. Just do the
exact same thing that Saudi Arabia is doing
but with the might of the Saudi population.
Surely a few hundred trolls had no chance against
a country with millions of people right? Well,
in theory yes, but Saudi Arabia isn’t
exactly putting up a fair fight. The
founder of the movement, Jamal Khashoggi,
has literally been assassinated and the
country has been arresting leaders of
the bee movement left and right. So,
join me as we explore Saudi Arabia’s quest to
extend their dictatorship into the online world.
A PRIVATE KINGDOM:
Taking a look back, the online space in Saudi
Arabia wasn’t always so animated. In fact,
the Saudi people didn’t even get internet till
1999 because the kingdom was concerned about
exactly this. Online protests, the spread of
dissenting ideas, and a more powerful societal
voice. But by 2000, the internet was getting so
big that continuing to ignore it would simply
leave the country behind. So, Saudi Arabia
would go ahead and implement a very limited
version of the internet. Saudi internet was to be
regulated by the King Abdulaziz City for Science
and Technology or KACST. KACST was responsible for
monitoring all internet traffic coming into the
country and ensuring that Saudi values and beliefs
were protected. To be honest, it’s not clear how
effective this organization was in actually
regulating internet traffic. But, its mere
existence itself was enough to deter people from
doing anything sus. After all, you didn’t want to
see what was on the other side of being caught.
So, people primarily just used the internet for
research and educational purposes as opposed
to social media or entertainment. This made the
kingdom rather closed off even though they were
technically connected to the internet but that
wasn’t a problem. In fact, that’s exactly what
the kingdom wanted. They didn’t care about western
perception or influencing the global narrative. As
long as the oil business was booming and they had
the Saudi people in line, that’s all they cared
about. But all of this would change on January 4,
2010. This day marked a monumental day for their
neighbors: the UAE as this was the grand opening
of the Burj Khalifa. At first glance, it was just
a another vanity tower but Dubai had grand plans
for this building. Dubai was going to use this
pointy structure to gain world wide relevance
through social media, travel, airlines, and even
movies. I mean who could forget the famous scene
were Tom Cruise scales the side of the Burj
Khalifa in Mission Impossible. This was by no
means Dubai’s first PR stunt. They had been trying
to shape global perception for decades because the
reality was that Dubai was a broke bum. They were
one of the only middle eastern cities that didn’t
have oil, so they were trying to build a tourist
hub which wasn’t working out all that great. In
fact, they literally went bankrupt trying to build
the Burj Khalifa and Abu Dhabi had to bail them
out. But, fortunately for Dubai, the Burj Khalifa
garnered more attention than they could have ever
dreamed of. Suddenly, everyone knew about the
Palm Islands, the Burj Al Arab, Atlantis The Palm,
the lavish malls, the lamborghini police, and of
course Emirates and their A380s. Almost overnight,
Dubai’s outlandish dreams of becoming a tourist
paradise became a reality. And all of their fake
fortunes became real fortunes. Saudi Arabia
didn’t really care about fortunes as Dubai’s
wealth was still peanuts in comparison to Saudi
wealth. But what did catch Saudi attention was
Dubai’s oil independence. Less than 1% of
Dubai’s GDP was coming from oil. Meanwhile,
nearly half of Saudi Arabia’s GDP was coming
from oil. It was time for something to change.
A CAUTIONARY TALE:
While all of this was unfolding MBS was barely
24 years old, but he already had the ears of the
country’s most powerful leaders. He held several
roles as a special advisor and a personal aide and
to him, the future of Saudi Arabia was clear. He
had to free Saudi Arabia from oil. He was going to
westernize the country, let in tourists in for the
first time, and revolutionize western perception.
But before he did all that, he would be met with
a harsh reminder of just what he was up against.
Between 2010 and 2012, the Middle East would be
rocked by a series of uprisings called the Arab
Spring. Essentially, a bunch of authoritarian
Middle Eastern countries would see massive
protests regarding human rights violations,
corruption, and wealth inequality. The protests
started in Tunisia but they would quickly
spread to Libya, Egypt, Yemen, Syria, and
Bahrain. And do you know what was central to all
of this? The internet. The usage of social media
doubled amongst these countries throughout the
Arab Spring. Social media was how activists were
able to communicate, organize, and retaliate. In
fact, 9 out of 10 Egyptians and Tunisians admitted
that they were using Facebook to organize protests
and spread awareness. The scariest part for these
dictators was that all of this was actually
working. In early 2011, Tunisia’s president
of 23 years, Ben Ali, would run away to Saudi
Arabia. Meanwhile, in Yemen, the president would
be nearly assassinated before he too would run
away to Saudi Arabia and cede power. This quickly
became a trend as the leaders of Egypt and Libya
would also end up resigining. The Middle East was
in turmoil and many of its leaders were turning
to Saudi Arabia for help. And Saudi Arabia would
indeed step in. In March of 2011, Saudi Arabia and
the UAE would send forces to Bahrain to occupy the
country and silence the protests. But, the UAE
and Saudi Arabia weren’t able to be the saviors
for long as protests started erupting in their own
countries. These guys wouldn’t be messing around
though. They had seen several of their peers get
overthrown by similar uprisings, so they would
put their foot down almost immediately. The UAE
would go out and arrest 94 of the most influential
journalists, lawyers, teachers, and student
activists and throw them in a secret prison.
Some of these individuals are still in prison to
this day. Meanwhile, Saudi Arabia’s military would
squash protests using brute force. Things were
looking worse than ever. Throughout much of the
Middle East, infrastructure had been demolished,
supply chains had been disrupted, inflation was
out of control, and poverty was reaching record
highs. And in the end, it was these internal
forces that would finally put an end to the
Arab Spring. As it became harder and harder
to just get by, people slowly lost the ability to
fight even if they still had the will to fight,
and pretty soon, the Arab Spring would turn
into the Arab Winter. Saudi Arabia had come out
victorious but MBS had seen first hand just how
dangerous the internet could be to authoritative
regimes. And let’s just say, MBS kept this in
mind when he became the crown prince in 2017.
A PROPAGANDA MACHINE:
MBS was set on westernizing the country.
He had this massive plan called Vision 2030
that was supposed to free Saudi Arabia
of its oil dependence. And honestly,
its actually a pretty fine plan. He was going to
invest their oil wealth into health, education,
infrastructure, recreation, and tourism but
this of course came with a caveat. He wanted to
revolutionize Saudi Arabia without ceding power.
And to make sure that he didn’t lose control,
he was going to build up an online army to
enforce his rule. But before he could do all this,
he first had to raise money. Vision 2030 entailed
spending hundreds of billions every single year so
he needed some pretty deep pockets. And who better
to get this from than Saudi’s elite. In late 2017,
MBS would round up the country’s 400 most powerful
people in a Ritz Carlton hotel and he would turn
the hotel into a jail. He basically told the elite
that they could leave as soon as they admitted
that they were quote on quote “corrupt” and paid
up. Were these people actually corrupt? Probably.
Did MBS actually care about their corruption
though? Probably not. This was simply a masterful
way to not only raise money but show the kingdom
who was really in control. And let’s just say,
he raised a lot of money. Over $100 billion
to be precise. This means that MBS milked a
cool quarter billion from each person. Not
a bad day’s work but that was just phase 1.
Phase 2 of his fundraising effort consisted of
taking their national oil company, Saudi Aramco,
public in the world’s largest IPO with a
valuation of $2 trillion. By this point,
MBS had the country’s wealth and leaders under
control. The next step was keeping the country’s
people in line despite the new freedoms. Enter
the Twitter Army. As we touched on in the intro,
MBS would straight up create an entire Twitter
battle station with the sole intent of promoting
his agenda across social media platforms. And
given how much manpower he’s dedicated to this
effort, it’s not surprising that it was quite
effective. Everything that was trending on Arab
Twitter was exactly what MBS wanted to trend. #1
Vision 2030. #2 Riyadh Rising. #3 MBS Rocks. #6
vision2030. #7 CrownPrince. Shout out to the Ace
Family though, they were literally able to out
perform state sponsored propaganda. Anyway, the
Saudi people would start referring this state
army as the flies and from that we would see a
new movement pop up called the bees. The bees
would do the exact same thing as the flies but
instant of pushing state sponsored propaganda,
the bees would push for social awareness and
political reform. The first viral hashtag
from the bees was “What do you know about the
bees” initially posted by the movements founder
Jamal Khashoggi. But just a few weeks after
this post went viral, Jamal Khashoggi would
be assassinated. The Saudis probably that this
would finally put an end to this movement but
it simply made it far stronger as it garnered
international attention and sympathy. This did
lead to Saudi Arabia backing down for a little
as they laid low avoiding the spotlight. But
there’s still a long road ahead as in the end,
the Saudi people are directly fighting against a
state sponsored propaganda machine backed by one
of the wealthiest countries on earth. All that
wealth may not last for long though. In fact,
there’s insider evidence that Saudi Arabia may
very well be lying about their oil reserves.
If you wanna learn more check out this video.